[SPEAKER_01]: Folsom returns on the summit of the Wealsun to his party.
[SPEAKER_04]: So they're here because of some mercenaries that have caused the havoc in the charter.
[SPEAKER_04]: Apparently there was bloodshed.
[SPEAKER_04]: Who was that?
[SPEAKER_04]: I don't know, but they assured that we're as safe as anyone here.
[SPEAKER_04]: Good to know.
[SPEAKER_04]: But I also asked him if there's any place that we can try to get a boat.
[SPEAKER_04]: Because I am a merchant.
[SPEAKER_04]: Now.
[SPEAKER_04]: And I asked him if we could get a boat.
[SPEAKER_04]: And he said we can go to the marshes.
[SPEAKER_04]: Because there's a new portal.
[SPEAKER_04]: Salt Marsh.
[SPEAKER_04]: There's a new portal in the Salt Marsh?
[SPEAKER_04]: Or, what was the other thing?
[SPEAKER_02]: I love Lizardmen.
[SPEAKER_02]: What was the other?
[SPEAKER_04]: Seaton.
[SPEAKER_04]: Or we can go to Seaton.
[SPEAKER_04]: How do we get to there?
[SPEAKER_04]: Which Seton is?
[SPEAKER_01]: So, Seton is... Yeah, how do we get to there?
[SPEAKER_01]: A town.
[SPEAKER_01]: You gotta get a boat to get anywhere.
[SPEAKER_01]: Seton's a little town over there.
[SPEAKER_02]: Where's the Soul Martians?
[SPEAKER_01]: Over there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: And Monmurg's over here.
[SPEAKER_04]: And if we go to Seton, we're gonna have to pass Kane Tolley's castle.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, but so that's the wrong direction.
[SPEAKER_03]: We have to get a boat in order to get to where we gotta go, no matter where.
[SPEAKER_04]: Tyrus, I love you, man.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm just, I'm just relaying the information I got.
[SPEAKER_01]: Apparently there is passage, though, into Keoland, away from Redshire.
[SPEAKER_03]: Hmm.
[SPEAKER_03]: We just head one way and then turn left.
[SPEAKER_03]: Works for NASCAR.
[SPEAKER_03]: What does this NASCAR use for?
[SPEAKER_02]: We can head and force them to go another way.
[SPEAKER_03]: That's a good thing to do.
[SPEAKER_03]: We're walking the docks this whole time.
[SPEAKER_02]: If they play nice, we can pay them.
[SPEAKER_03]: Is there any of these boats that we walk along that look very similar to
[SPEAKER_01]: You're walking down the docks, right?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, we're walking down the docks.
[SPEAKER_03]: These boats, they're a similar type of a boat to the one we came on.
[SPEAKER_01]: There are a lot of sloops like that.
[SPEAKER_03]: Now, in all of our experience collectively here, we had to have known there's some sort of more seedy people than others that run these sloops.
[SPEAKER_03]: There's a family of three on this one and the next one has some one-eyed dude with a grizzled beard.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, there's got to be in our collective sloops.
[SPEAKER_03]: We thought process here.
[SPEAKER_03]: We should be able to pick out one that's easier to slip away out on another or somebody who is a lot less scrupulous than the others.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, we can try to get passage and then try to force the passage elsewhere by promise of coin or death.
[SPEAKER_02]: And then there's trying to take one ourself at night by forcing them to do it or... Let's take a home mental war.
[SPEAKER_02]: Buying ourselves onto one for passage.
[SPEAKER_03]: Buy ourselves on the way.
[SPEAKER_02]: Steal one or get passage and then divert.
[SPEAKER_03]: And then divert them.
[SPEAKER_03]: But we need to find somebody who's a little less, more likely to use coin than others.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Collectively, can we find a boat as we walk along that we think kind of sticks out as a little less... Well, I mean, you have insight into these things.
[SPEAKER_01]: If you want to roll your insight, roll.
[SPEAKER_01]: I do.
[SPEAKER_01]: Can I also do that?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, sure.
[SPEAKER_01]: You guys walk up and down the docks looking for seedy ships.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nope.
[SPEAKER_01]: I got eight.
[SPEAKER_01]: Twenty.
[SPEAKER_02]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm going to throw into it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Seventeen.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you guys are walking up and down the docks.
[SPEAKER_01]: Maybe we see the same.
[SPEAKER_01]: And actually, there is a ship that the three of you, which is strange,
[SPEAKER_01]: All recognize in the docks.
[SPEAKER_01]: And actually, you realize individually this captain is another spy from Lord Jameis, well known by you as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: In fact, he's so obvious to you.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's obvious to these guys, but he's obvious to you as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's a messenger, actually.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's been rumored to work for Lord Jameis, and this is his ship.
[SPEAKER_01]: You have no idea who this is.
[SPEAKER_00]: Who is he?
[SPEAKER_01]: Merrick, you do know this guy.
[SPEAKER_01]: I do.
[SPEAKER_01]: His name is Captain Helms, and
[SPEAKER_01]: He's kind of a character, but he's loyal to Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_01]: And the fact that he's here is actually very serendipitous to you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Let me go have a discussion with this fella.
[SPEAKER_03]: Let's all go to that ship.
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, maybe not all of us at once.
[SPEAKER_03]: I don't know if we walk on it like we know what we're doing.
[SPEAKER_00]: We'll follow behind you.
[SPEAKER_00]: Somebody do the talking.
[SPEAKER_00]: You do.
[SPEAKER_00]: You go chat.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: You go chat.
[SPEAKER_01]: We can all go together.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you walk down the docks, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Up to the ship.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you see a first maid.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sleeping in a hammock that goes from the mast to the, not the wheelhouse, what is that thing?
[SPEAKER_01]: It's basically the cabins just laying there.
[SPEAKER_01]: How big is he?
[SPEAKER_01]: You know, not as big as you, but not a small man.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_03]: Do you know him?
[SPEAKER_03]: Do I know him?
[SPEAKER_03]: Have I seen him?
[SPEAKER_01]: Roll your insight check.
[SPEAKER_01]: 16 plus 4?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, you do know him.
[SPEAKER_01]: Kind of a slow cargo handler that's worked on the Harbor District.
[SPEAKER_01]: Not a bad guy.
[SPEAKER_01]: But, you know, he actually worked for your uncle.
[SPEAKER_01]: He would probably remember you.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: Lock up.
[SPEAKER_01]: Give him a little shake.
[SPEAKER_01]: He wakes up and kind of looks at you and goes, Am I in Monmurg?
[SPEAKER_03]: Not yet, buddy.
[SPEAKER_03]: Not yet.
[SPEAKER_03]: Good to see ya.
[SPEAKER_03]: What are you doing here?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, put my hands, give him the shake and rattle him awake and everything like that.
[SPEAKER_03]: Good to see ya.
[SPEAKER_01]: Keaton kind of gets up, what are you doing here?
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm looking for Hel, Hel, Hel, Captain Helm.
[SPEAKER_03]: Captain Helm, I'm looking for Captain Helm.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's in the cabin.
[SPEAKER_01]: Tyrus, he looks down the dock at the three of you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Three other of you stay on the dock.
[SPEAKER_01]: He goes, are you sure we're not in Monmurg?
[SPEAKER_03]: Not yet.
[SPEAKER_03]: Not yet, my friend, but soon we will be.
[SPEAKER_01]: Am I dreaming?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_03]: And head towards the cabin.
[SPEAKER_03]: Head towards the cabin.
[SPEAKER_03]: Let me get Helm.
[SPEAKER_01]: You stay here.
[SPEAKER_01]: You three, come on board.
[SPEAKER_01]: Lay low.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: I go over, slide down, sit against the side, bust out a flask.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm going to look out over the ship and look at the sea and the dock and stuff.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't see anything.
[SPEAKER_01]: You see, you know, marines walking down the dock in that direction.
[SPEAKER_00]: Hey, Tyrus, we're gonna need to talk to Helm pretty quick here, man.
[SPEAKER_00]: Got it.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think we're all gonna move to the quarters real quick.
[SPEAKER_00]: Gouge quarters.
[SPEAKER_00]: Let's get below deck.
[SPEAKER_03]: We'll all go with you.
[SPEAKER_03]: Come on.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, so you guys march into the thing.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's crowded in there, but you get out of the cover, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: And, um...
[SPEAKER_01]: Basically, knocks on the cabin.
[SPEAKER_01]: You hear, what do you want?
[SPEAKER_00]: I told you to leave me here.
[SPEAKER_00]: Got my drink on last night.
[SPEAKER_01]: We have visitors.
[SPEAKER_01]: He goes, ah, can't be that important.
[SPEAKER_03]: Captain Helm, Tyrus, gotta speak to you, buddy.
[SPEAKER_01]: Tyrus, what is that pirate doing here?
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, bust open the door.
[SPEAKER_01]: Letting the light in.
[SPEAKER_01]: What do you want, boy?
[SPEAKER_01]: What are you doing in Red Shore?
[SPEAKER_03]: We're not going to be in Red Shore for long.
[SPEAKER_01]: He actually looks back and goes, Oh, he looks at you and he goes, What are you doing here, lad?
[SPEAKER_01]: You're bringing bad luck to me.
[SPEAKER_01]: Um, did the spider send ya?
[SPEAKER_01]: Spider?
[SPEAKER_01]: He's talking about Jameis.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh.
[SPEAKER_01]: I know that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right?
[SPEAKER_01]: What's that?
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Hey, I hate to- Don't worry about it, buddy.
[SPEAKER_00]: We won't be here for long.
[SPEAKER_00]: We'll be here, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: I hate to tell you- We need to get back to the spider.
[SPEAKER_00]: Might be bringing you bad luck, but we gotta get back- Did I hear a fucking pirate's voice?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, mine.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is GOUGE back there!
[SPEAKER_01]: Sir, I'm also here.
[SPEAKER_02]: I... You do.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're blowing my cover!
[SPEAKER_00]: Get in the cabin now!
[SPEAKER_01]: So, you guys come in and he's like...
[SPEAKER_01]: He's scared.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: What are you doing here?
[SPEAKER_01]: You're blowing my cover.
[SPEAKER_03]: Don't worry about it, buddy.
[SPEAKER_01]: He goes, sit down, get in the corner.
[SPEAKER_01]: Don't worry about it.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is a small 10 by 10 room.
[SPEAKER_03]: Don't worry about it.
[SPEAKER_03]: And there were like six men, smelly men.
[SPEAKER_03]: In here.
[SPEAKER_01]: In here, right now.
[SPEAKER_01]: One of them is the size of two of them.
[SPEAKER_01]: And this guy is wearing his, you know, long johns and obviously he's been peeing his pants because he's not getting enough to urinate.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's an older guy.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's probably 60 with white horny hair and a big old beard.
[SPEAKER_01]: Been on the seas forever.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's not a legend.
[SPEAKER_03]: But he's infamous.
[SPEAKER_03]: Don't worry about it.
[SPEAKER_03]: We have good news.
[SPEAKER_03]: Stay here, shut up.
[SPEAKER_01]: We got good news for you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Hey, shut up!
[SPEAKER_01]: We got good news.
[SPEAKER_01]: He walks out the door, hand over his mouth.
[SPEAKER_01]: Shut the fuck up.
[SPEAKER_01]: He walks outside, he looks out.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, Marines, Marines, Marines.
[SPEAKER_01]: They're passing by.
[SPEAKER_01]: He kind of does that, and he goes,
[SPEAKER_01]: Shuts the door and lights a candle.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's dark in this room.
[SPEAKER_01]: It does not smell good or anything like that.
[SPEAKER_01]: He goes, What are you doing here, lads?
[SPEAKER_01]: Don't worry.
[SPEAKER_01]: We got good news.
[SPEAKER_01]: Tyrus, you're with two of the biggest.
[SPEAKER_01]: Don't worry.
[SPEAKER_03]: We have good news.
[SPEAKER_03]: You're going back to Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_03]: How?
[SPEAKER_03]: We're leaving tonight.
[SPEAKER_03]: That I don't know.
[SPEAKER_03]: But you are going back to Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_00]: Helm.
[SPEAKER_00]: Think about that.
[SPEAKER_00]: How did we get out of here?
[SPEAKER_00]: Helm, I was sent here as a spy as well to get information to bring back to Jameis.
[SPEAKER_03]: That doesn't matter.
[SPEAKER_03]: All you gotta worry about Helm is how do we get out of here tonight.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, we have to get out of here.
[SPEAKER_03]: I have information for Jameis.
[SPEAKER_03]: If you could leave sooner, that would be better.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is the only ship I know that we can get out of here on.
[SPEAKER_00]: What was your point?
[SPEAKER_02]: Were you going to be here?
[SPEAKER_02]: Were you going back to Monmurg?
[SPEAKER_02]: Is anything going to look out of the ordinary?
[SPEAKER_02]: What is he going to do?
[SPEAKER_01]: He kind of looks at you and goes, you know I don't trust you.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, you shouldn't.
[SPEAKER_01]: But the good news is, you're going back to Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_01]: How am I going back to Monmurg?
[SPEAKER_01]: At night.
[SPEAKER_01]: Whatever you gotta do to get out of this house.
[SPEAKER_01]: Where's the fleet?
[SPEAKER_01]: I've been asking to go back to Monmurg for two weeks now.
[SPEAKER_01]: Three weeks.
[SPEAKER_01]: What do you gotta do to get out of here?
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, so you're stuck in the embargo here.
[SPEAKER_02]: You're not slipping into it.
[SPEAKER_03]: They're not letting anyone out but the mail ships.
[SPEAKER_03]: All we gotta do is go to Saltmarsh.
[SPEAKER_03]: Tell them you're going to Saltmarsh.
[SPEAKER_01]: They're not gonna let me out of here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, sure.
[SPEAKER_01]: With four marines on my boat, they will.
[SPEAKER_01]: Who's asking you?
[SPEAKER_04]: Or who's telling you you can't?
[SPEAKER_01]: Admiral Amrachar, on that boat over there, the Keago man-of-war is the one that tells who can go and who cannot.
[SPEAKER_01]: And believe me, I've talked to him.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's not gonna let me go home.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're making fish.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's a rotten fish shoe.
[SPEAKER_03]: We could go to Salt Marsh and we could go, where else could we go?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, we can't go anywhere.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, we can.
[SPEAKER_00]: Tell me about this dude who...
[SPEAKER_00]: No, we can go to Saltmarsh or we can go to, which is the other one?
[SPEAKER_00]: Can't go anywhere right now.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Not to this ship.
[SPEAKER_00]: We need to talk.
[SPEAKER_03]: The two places, the two places you said we could go was Saltmarsh.
[SPEAKER_03]: Hope.
[SPEAKER_01]: Listen, Tyrus.
[SPEAKER_01]: They're not going to let any ship go to Saltmarsh or any ship go to Seton.
[SPEAKER_01]: They're not a Marine detachment on board to take their wares there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Not a problem.
[SPEAKER_03]: What if I were?
[SPEAKER_03]: Get a few Marines on the ship.
[SPEAKER_03]: What if I were to charm them?
[SPEAKER_03]: So I'm saying, what if we got a few marines on the ship?
[SPEAKER_03]: We can take a few marines.
[SPEAKER_03]: How do you talk to this admiral?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, you gotta go petition him.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're a charming lad, and you might be able to do it, but I'd hate the cost you'd have to pay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Cost?
[SPEAKER_03]: You know what I mean?
[SPEAKER_01]: Couldn't go alone.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm not gonna let him go alone.
[SPEAKER_01]: I wouldn't sell a lad for that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: You need to go talk to him.
[SPEAKER_01]: But he can't go along.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll go with you.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, I'll go with him.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, luckily, I'm of no help here on that.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'll go with him.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, that's fine.
[SPEAKER_00]: You go with him.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_03]: Then we'll go talk to him.
[SPEAKER_03]: And what do we need him to do?
[SPEAKER_03]: Sign off on what?
[SPEAKER_03]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: Clean up a little.
[SPEAKER_01]: A lot.
[SPEAKER_03]: So what are you doing here?
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, Helm, we're getting out of here is what we're doing.
[SPEAKER_01]: We're in the wrong place at the wrong time.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't want to know what you want to do.
[SPEAKER_01]: I want to know why you're here.
[SPEAKER_00]: So Helm, I was sent here to spy for Janus.
[SPEAKER_00]: Owen Black.
[SPEAKER_00]: In and out of Redshore.
[SPEAKER_00]: I've seen that rascal around here.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, so we came on in his cruiser.
[SPEAKER_00]: Our charming little lad here found out a lot more information than he should have.
[SPEAKER_00]: He loosened Owen's tongue a little too much.
[SPEAKER_00]: Owen's put out for us now.
[SPEAKER_00]: We've ran into some trouble, but we have valuable information we need to get back to Monmurg that's gonna help free Redshore.
[SPEAKER_00]: And prosper the city of Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_00]: The sooner we do this, the better.
[SPEAKER_00]: What are the plans here?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, what we're thinking, if we can get our bard to go talk to this admiral and woo him enough to either A, let this ship pass.
[SPEAKER_00]: Brive him.
[SPEAKER_00]: Transform marines, bribe him, whatever we need to do.
[SPEAKER_00]: Or find out what ships will be passing tonight.
[SPEAKER_01]: How important is this information for Jameis?
[SPEAKER_03]: Extremely.
[SPEAKER_03]: The most important information he needs to know right now.
[SPEAKER_03]: So that means to me that it would help break the blockade.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's what we gotta do.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: The blockade here would be down.
[SPEAKER_00]: The passage, you know the mysterious storms that are blocking the direct passage from here to Monmurg?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Let's just say we don't have to worry about that anymore, or for a time being, but I don't know how long that is going to be, so we need to start moving as quick as possible because we have a small glimpse of opportunity to get Monmurg in and out of here.
[SPEAKER_00]: Helm, you know I know these waters.
[SPEAKER_00]: I know you know these waters.
[SPEAKER_00]: You need to trust me on this.
[SPEAKER_01]: I told you I've been in communication with Jameis these last several weeks.
[SPEAKER_01]: How so?
[SPEAKER_01]: Pigeons.
[SPEAKER_01]: I've got three in the hold right now left for it.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's been asking me questions.
[SPEAKER_01]: He put me here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Can you write this letter and I can give it to Jameis?
[SPEAKER_01]: Because I'm telling you, Admiral Armarchar is not going to let us out of here.
[SPEAKER_01]: When he takes one look at you, and definitely you, there's no way we're free.
[SPEAKER_01]: This lad could probably go on a mail ship to Saltmarsh or Seaton.
[SPEAKER_01]: No one else is getting out of here now.
[SPEAKER_01]: What if we send the pigeons now?
[SPEAKER_04]: I was going to suggest putting Merrick and Gouge in cargo and bringing it up on a mail ship, but the pigeon is the only, the best resource we have.
[SPEAKER_00]: A pigeon's going to get to Monmurg fast and then a sail.
[SPEAKER_00]: It'll break the embargo though, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Then we can get out of here.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm not sure if we need to actually sail the waters to make sure it's clear.
[SPEAKER_02]: I see what you mean.
[SPEAKER_02]: To know if I... That was the whole reason.
[SPEAKER_02]: You're going and making sure.
[SPEAKER_00]: If that's clear.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, we can't send a pigeon in the hopes that it's clear and it's not.
[SPEAKER_02]: We called the Monmurgian Navy into a death trap.
[SPEAKER_00]: How many miles out of that?
[SPEAKER_00]: From where we are, I assume it's miles and miles away.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's 60 miles to Monmurg, but...
[SPEAKER_01]: This is where you saw King Toli two days ago.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is 60 miles.
[SPEAKER_01]: That is 80 miles and he was still heading that way.
[SPEAKER_03]: How long does it take to get one of these rats with wings to a Monmurg?
[SPEAKER_03]: He'll get the message probably within 20 hours.
[SPEAKER_03]: Gives us plenty of time to go visit
[SPEAKER_03]: The king here.
[SPEAKER_03]: The earl.
[SPEAKER_03]: The earl here.
[SPEAKER_00]: We need to send a pigeon, though.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's fine.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, we just need to tell everything I just told you I'm telling Jameis.
[SPEAKER_01]: If you men want to go and try and leave this town and fight an entire contingent of men at war, that's fine.
[SPEAKER_01]: But I can get you a message to Jameis if you write it for me.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yep, that's fine.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll even let you guys, you rats, stay in the hold like the other rats do and hide out here until we know more.
[SPEAKER_04]: I would say we write the letter and then wait for James to write us back to see the best plan of action.
[SPEAKER_03]: I mean, this is what I kind of think will be written back.
[SPEAKER_03]: I think we'll see the Monmurg and Navy coming back.
[SPEAKER_03]: Right, and I think by that time it's gonna take 20 hours for a pigeon to get there.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's gonna take
[SPEAKER_03]: More than that for a Navy to sail this direction.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's not true.
[SPEAKER_03]: How long can a Navy...
[SPEAKER_01]: The boats would be there in like 15.
[SPEAKER_03]: So we're talking two days.
[SPEAKER_03]: Less than two days.
[SPEAKER_03]: Day and a half.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_03]: To get there and back.
[SPEAKER_01]: In the meantime...
[SPEAKER_01]: It'd probably take four hours to get shaken.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: It'd be less than two days.
[SPEAKER_00]: Helm, show me to your pigeons.
[SPEAKER_01]: In the meantime, write the letter.
[SPEAKER_01]: My pigeons are my business.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll take care of them myself.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sounds good.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, I'm going to write out a letter.
[SPEAKER_00]: Dick's going to write out a letter.
[SPEAKER_00]: I do want to write out a letter.
[SPEAKER_01]: Posterity.
[SPEAKER_03]: Dot, dot, dot.
[SPEAKER_02]: Send out some baby dot, dot, dot.
[SPEAKER_02]: Are you the six-fingered guy?
[SPEAKER_02]: This is posterity, remember?
[SPEAKER_01]: Six-fingered man.
[SPEAKER_00]: If I write, it's going to go to Helm, this is going to go to... No, wait a minute.
[SPEAKER_03]: You send this letter.
[SPEAKER_03]: Did you check to make sure that there were no dragons on that side of the island?
[SPEAKER_01]: So by the way, it is going to be coded because you know how to code it.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: But did you check and make sure there were no dragons when we were on that side?
[SPEAKER_03]: You did not.
[SPEAKER_00]: Negative.
[SPEAKER_00]: I can look.
[SPEAKER_00]: We send a navy.
[SPEAKER_00]: Let me write this out.
[SPEAKER_00]: We'll go look.
[SPEAKER_00]: Then we'll send it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Before you see it, you should check.
[SPEAKER_01]: Merrick's concerned about this.
[SPEAKER_00]: Let me go out on the deck really quick.
[SPEAKER_00]: Come with me, if you don't mind.
[SPEAKER_00]: Go out on the deck.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm going to scan the seeds.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do I see anything wrong?
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want to go on deck and look in the redshirt to see if there are any...
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let's go talk.
[SPEAKER_01]: I grabbed your collar.
[SPEAKER_01]: Grab his collar.
[SPEAKER_01]: Merrick?
[SPEAKER_02]: Remember, you've already said too much, so do not tell him anything more.